[Music]
well so Enrique well he's just the he's
just the coolest dude on the science
faculty I gotta say Cuban right yes yeah
yeah
Cuban went to school in the part of the
roughest parts of Newark right went to
college it records where he got his
bachelor's I did his PhD with Tom
Pollard who spoke in this series when he
was at Johns Hopkins he did a postdoc at
at Penn and we've been great too very
fortunate to have him here on the
faculty ever since he's also the the
head of a college is what it's called
now the head of a college yeah and and
he's gonna tell you about how he became
a scientist and and how snakes and worms
crawl how you know we do push-ups and
pull-ups it's just just awesome so join
me in welcoming professor de la Cruz
Thank You Kurt and welcome everyone
thank you for for putting these events
on and I thank all of you for being here
it's really a pleasure and a privilege
to be here I think my kids are outside
but it's okay I am the least interesting
person on their radar so it's completely
understandable but I sincerely thank you
for for being here
Kurt professor zoom just gave away a
little bit of my introduction basically
Who I am and where I came from but I'd
like to repeat some of that in in the
appropriate context so that you can
realize like ratatouille a scientist can
come from anywhere and that is that
anyone can be a scientist and so my life
before coming to Yale which was started
18 years ago is when I arrived at Yale
I'm a first-generation American my
mother father and sister were born in
Cuba this is a picture of my mother and
my father and my big sister
shortly after my mother and sister came
to the United States this is a very
interesting story when we realize how
difficult our challenges might be you
know I know my life is can be difficult
at times but my mother and father were
married in Cuba and they were in their
early 20s and because of the political
climate the the Castro regime was coming
into power and there was a lot of exodus
of the people from from Cuba and my
father left Cuba before my mother and in
fact he left a pregnant wife behind and
came to the United States and he went to
a Dallas and then eventually ended up in
New Jersey which I'll show you in a
moment and my mother stayed behind with
this this young child that had yet to be
born and it took her about two years to
finally get out of Cuba and she had to
go through Spain before coming to the
United States and this picture was taken
shortly after they got back together
again in the United States and so when
you think of the sacrifices that we all
do on a daily basis which I know I do
for my own children and then I simply
consider the sacrifices that my family
made for their children which had yet to
even be born it pales in comparison to
anything that I can imagine would be
difficult in my life and I adore and
respect them both as well as my sister
and my brother who incidentally was born
shortly afterwards dad I was born in
Newark New Jersey this beautiful little
nice little logo here shows it all for
those of you that only Newark
know Newark as Newark Airport this is
where it is on a map Manhattan's over
here on the other side and I was born in
the late 60s and I grew up in the early
70s in Newark and many of you may
remember the older people obviously I
remember that this is what Newark really
looked like in the 1970s as many urban
centers in
it states in the 1970s it was a very
difficult time economically and there
was a lot of poverty crime and neglect
of the inner city and this revealed
itself very clearly in the education
system so we were going to Catholic
school my brother sister and I were
going to a Catholic school which was the
the the best schools that my family
could afford to send us to but naturally
they couldn't afford to send three
children to school so we moved right
across the river a convenient walking
distance into a town Carney I was in
second grade when we moved over there
and I went to the public school system
and I graduated from Kearney high school
and and that that is my education in
high school and I had experiences there
which encouraged me to be a scientist
and this is what I really want to
communicate to the young people here you
know so when and how did I decide to be
a scientist okay because this this is
something that I actually think and
wonder and worry about I've dedicated my
life to teaching and education and I've
always wondered what makes people do
something and why because the friends
that I grew up with are not scientists
hey and so and I I'd like to think I'm
special but the truth is I know I'm not
terribly different from them and so I'd
like to say ever since I was a little
kid I wanted to be a scientist but
that's not true
and if I said that I'd be lying that's
not to dismiss any young person here who
wants to be a scientist I wanted to be a
cop all right our fireman okay but you
know so I can't say that to you and and
in fact I don't really know how I became
a scientist but I'm beginning to piece
it together now that I'm almost 50 years
old and I think the real the real reason
for being a scientist is this this quote
from Joe Goldstein who basically says if
we're facing in the right direction all
we have to do is keep walking and so the
question is is how did I find the right
direction and as every parent here knows
and
we'll realize someday it was my mom and
dad in particular okay and so here's
here's a here's an image where my mom
and dad they didn't tell me to be a
scientist in fact they they they're not
scientists but they in human culture
education is central we you know I
personally value almost not value more
than anything else but among the things
I value most in life is in education and
that is not to say that I value educated
people but I value education so much
that I think everyone should have it and
and my parents this was central they
said you can do whatever you want but
you have to go to school for something
and my brother sister and I all went to
school and we all went to college and
and got some professional degrees I'm so
I thank my mother and father as well as
my brother and sister for leading by
example but it was when I was in high
school
16 years old when I started working in a
lab so I participated in these
work-study programs where you would go
to school for half a day take the state
requirements gym English I don't
remember the other ones history or
something and then I would go and I went
to work at hoffman-laroche I would get
on the bus I'd have to take three buses
to get to hoffman-laroche so that I can
actually work and that's when I started
working in a lab and that's when I got
the book okay that the if once you get
your hands in a laboratory that's when
you're hooked and I was lucky enough to
have it when I was 16 more than
two-thirds of my life I've been working
in the lab I don't really know how to do
anything else just ask my wife
that's what but nevertheless this was a
wonderful experience that that made me
curious and made me want to learn more
about science and so I went I applied to
college and I applied to one school
Rutgers why because I'm from New Jersey
right so I applied to Rutgers and it was
wonderful place I am completely indebted
to my experience there and I
particularly want to thank this man
right there by Rico Masaryk as well as
Chris Rebelo and a gentleman named
Harvey fader who was chair of the
biology department because Berry was
heading this program called the mbrs
program has anyone ever heard of it no
it's the minority biomedical research
support program and I recently went to
their 25th anniversary for this program
being in Newark and I realized I didn't
know at the time that I had entered this
program in its second year and berry
told me something really interesting at
the time which may come as a surprise to
some of you but perhaps not to others
and he said to me you know it was really
surprising that back then in the 1980s
people really thought that minorities
african-americans Hispanics either
didn't want to do science or couldn't do
science and he dedicated 25 years of his
life saved a small little hiatus that he
took to have this program put in place
so that individuals like this guy can
get their hands wet in the laboratory
and consider being a scientist and that
was an absolutely transformative
experience and because of that I
actually decided to apply to graduate
school and be a scientist and I applied
to several schools I was very lucky and
I decided to go to Johns Hopkins and I
worked with this guy Tom Pollard who
incidentally was the Dean of our
graduate school he's now my colleague
here at Yale but he was at Johns Hopkins
at the time and I worked with him I got
my PhD and then I went and I worked with
my Kostov who was a friend of mine and
Leigh Sweeney who was a leader in the
field at the University of Pennsylvania
and so you know what I want to point out
here what do you see here you see four
four white dudes if I may use the term
this is a reminder that not everyone
should be demonized for whatever reason
particularly for their gender or their
ethnicity but more important
a reminder that there are a lot of good
people in the world okay and on a good
day
and I emphasize a good day I am simply
an example of what can happen what can
result when good people step up and
actually take concern and care and
commit their efforts to help somebody
else I worked with them
I came to Yale in 2001 September 10th
2001 those of you that are familiar with
dates and were around at the time my
second day at Yale was not a very
pleasant day particularly since my
mother father sister and brother lived
in the New York area and I joined the
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
department and I've been here ever since
I lived happily ever after as they say
and what was perhaps most exciting about
this was the the number of people that I
got to work with okay I'm a teacher I
teach classes I write grants I advise
students as professors Ilham said I'm
head of a college but as a scientist I
run a lab and these are just snapshots
of the different people that I was able
to work with over these 18 years that's
that's my muscle that's my bread and
butter right there these are the people
that I work with and I've committed my
life to their careers and as a result
they've helped mine and we've worked on
many things sorry many things molecular
motor proteins myosins HeLa cases these
enzymes that burn fuel and and do work
on these systems we work on lipid
cleaving enzymes and some calcification
enzymes with my colleague Demetrios
Braddock down in the pathology
department at the medical school here
and we've actually used a lot of our
basic science in this area to develop
potential therapeutics and there's a
company now we've we've been working on
an enzyme that looks like it's very
promising to serve as a therapeutic for
some human disorders and there's and
there's a company that's actively
working on starting clinical trials on
this but I'm not going to tell you about
that I'm gonna actually tell you about
some basic science why because when I
became a scientist I didn't want to save
the world I didn't wanna
pure a disease I was just curious I was
just interested in the world around me I
was fascinated by what the world offered
and I was fascinated even more when I
could understand how it did what it did
and so while we think of Oh what is
science good for ok we often think you
know diseases medicine but science is
good for knowledge and education and
basic science is trying to understand
how the world works
with the understanding that this
information can be used to understand
things when they don't go wrong and I
would posit that we don't even have the
capacity to know in advance what use
this information will offer in the
future and so this is a problem that I'm
actually working on that I'm going to
share with you this shows a white blood
cell a neutrophil that's chasing a
little bacterium this is a film taken by
David Rodgers at Vanderbilt University
in the 1950s and you can see that the
the white blood cell is chasing this
bacterium the bacterium secreting some
things that the cell can sense but it's
chasing it and it's trying to fight that
infection and this problem itself how
this cell moves around is what I'm
interested in okay it's a complex
process and I'm going to focus on a
small aspect of this but if you look
inside one of these highly motile cells
you see these fibers these long chains
or filaments and this is called the
actin cytoskeleton because it's made out
of a protein called actin and there it's
called the cytoskeleton which means this
the the skeleton of the cell so it's
essentially the bones of the cell it
gives the cell mechanical strength it
gives it stability and in highly motile
cells like this it can actually allow
them to crawl ok and how does it allow
them to crawl quite simply because this
little protein exists in two forms
so it's exists like a little protein
about this big doesn't details don't
matter here but when it forms these
chains it generates a force that
push a boundary forward and that
boundary can be the front part of the
cell it could be a pathogenic bacterium
it can be a plastic bead which I'll show
you in a moment
and it's this assembly of this protein
that's critical for generating these
kinds of movements and here's a movie
that illustrates this is from a
manuscript published in 2007 which
illustrates how this assembly can push
something and this is the front part of
this cell here the membrane and you can
see that as these chains start to grow
just like this little thing right there
it can push it forward and that's the
force that pushes this cell forward now
because the cell is a closed system we
don't have an infinite supply of these
little protein subunits we have to
recycle those subunits
okay those subunits they grow
preferentially on one end of this
polymer so it grows this way and it
preferentially shrinks from the other
but those little protein subunits have
to be recycled and this is a complex
process with many proteins involved but
the concept of recycling the subunits is
central in order for this to work for an
extended period of time and there's a
protein in all of our bodies in all of
our cells except perhaps our red blood
cells called cofilin and it's so
biological function apparently is to
break these actin filaments to allow
them to fall apart and why is that
because if you have something like this
that only grows and shrinks from the
ends I have a given amount which you can
see right here and if I just change it
the lengths I've now doubled the places
where it can grow and where it can
shrink from and this protein this is
exactly what it does and here's a cute
little animation which illustrates that
process I can have one long chain that's
falling apart on either on on the ends
in this this video but if I cut it you
see that
the little pieces are gone and that
other one is still waiting the go away
so this protein is actually responsible
for recycling these subunits by breaking
this actin filament now this protein
called cofilin
the biologists knew it was an
interesting protein why because if you
get rid of it in a fly yeast the worm
those organisms are dead that's a term
that means it's an essential protein and
if you're missing it or you compromised
its activity you display a lethal
phenotype or you look really really
really really sick in some cases but the
biochemists also knew it was an
interesting protein because you can take
a series of proteins and drop them in
like right here this is simply a plastic
bead that my friend Laurent Blashaw this
video he took he throws a plastic bead
inside a tube with a new number of
purified proteins and that bead starts
moving with the velocity the persistence
the directionality similar to those
cells so you can reconstitute this
behavior and if this protein cofilin is
not there the system stalls and it's
gets sluggish and it can't keep up with
the needs of cells now the interesting
part from a physical and material
science perspective is that an actin
filament these fibers that you see
inside of these cells are about as hard
as commercial plastic they're like
Plexiglas so if I were to blindfold you
and give you a cylinder of given
dimensions made out of Plexiglas and one
made out of this little protein that I
just told you about actin you couldn't
distinguish one from the other remember
they have to be super strong and stable
to move these things and generate these
forces but the cell is faced with this
challenge that it has to break these
things and recycle these subunits very
quickly now what makes Co fill in
particularly interesting is that it can
break this plastic by just binding by
just interacting now I want to ask
if I were to tell you to break something
think in your head what would you do now
cells have proteins that burn fuel and
they squeeze and they pull and they
stretch and they and they they share but
this protein cofilin can break the
plastic by just interacting with it just
touching it like shaking hands it will
cause it to break and so that is an
interesting physics and make material
science problem because how do you break
plastic so quickly and efficiently but
it also becomes a chemistry problem by
definition specifically a thermodynamics
problem because all of the information
needed to break this plastic is in the
interaction energy and so I would argue
that if you want to understand this
process and how to break it you need to
do biology you need to do biochemistry
you need to do chemistry you need to do
physics you need to do mathematics you
need to impose engineering principles as
well and we've done all of these things
but let me tell you what got me
interested in the first place that
sounds like a very convincing argument
if you wanted to recruit anyone from
different fields but let me ask you a
simple question because I I've told you
that it's curiosity that keeps us going
as scientists okay so here's a very
simple question okay let's say I want
you to break this pencil okay and I say
I want you to break that pencil right
there with that red tape Asst I'm gonna
give you a choice okay how many of you
would do this and try to bend it like
that and how many of you would do that
how many of you who do the first one die
the biologists say how many of you would
do this ah many of you okay all right
let's let's mix it up a little bit all
right if you wanted to break it there
now how many of you would do this how
many of you do this oh how many of you
would do this okay all right
why okay you can answer that think of
that but that's the question I'm
actually interested in that's why I got
interested in this problem ten years ago
okay it's like how do you determine
where this plastic breaks and how do you
localize a force if you do at all to
cause it to break and that's what
initially got me interested in this mess
and ten years later I learned a lot of
interesting things but that's the
question that I want to try to address
to you today how does a cell do this
because it does it doesn't and in some
cases hundreds of times per second and
cells despite being stochastic as we all
know they kind of know what they're
doing and they have a lot of practice
and they're very good at this and so the
question is how do you where do you
break how do you determine where you
break and how do you break and that's
what I'm actually gonna focus on so I
first started working on this we knew
quite a bit my friend Amy McGough she
started a lot you can learn a lot by
looking she took a picture of an actin
filament in the microscope now here's a
rope that captures the sort of helical
nature of this polymer and what she saw
is that an actin filament kind of looks
like that okay it's not exactly the same
but I think it'll make the point and if
what she saw is when this little protein
cofilin which I colored in blue bound it
did this it changed to twist a little
bit could you see that anyone see that
maybe I'll do it this way so it's more
dramatic that's actually more accurate
okay it's a tiny change if you can't see
it it's because it's a small change okay
but she saw this and this was incredibly
influential because it provided an
indication as how you might break it and
the generally accepted wisdom in the
field I was written in our books is that
this species right there when the
cofilin in blue binds to this chain of
actin this thing is stable and this
thing falls apart and that sounded good
I heard it so many times I believed it
and then my mother would say if this
thing falls apart how'd she take a
picture of it
right okay all right well let's see
let's get back to that okay but I argued
that since the severing is driven by
binding that is the interaction of this
thing just sitting on there right there
is what causes it to break this this to
a chemist means you need thermodynamic
information and by that I just mean I
need to understand the energy of that
interaction because all of the
information to cause this fragmentation
is buried in that interaction energy and
if we understand that we know how to
think about the possible ways that you
could break this plastic and so we do
this by simply measuring how they
interact with each other and there are
many experiments that you can do with
this but I'll give you a very simple
example we do something called
fluorescence you can consider it like
glowing in the dark so imagine that I
had my chain of actin and a glue glowed
in the dark and every time the co
filling came in it sort of masked the
glowing in the dark so I could measure
the interaction by simply measuring how
bright it is okay and that's a
spectroscopic assay which I know you've
had in this science on Saturdays before
but we can measure the interaction of
these things and then what we do is we
generate a graph okay this oh there's a
lot of information in here but let me
just tell you what it's saying this is
telling me how many blue Co feelings are
bound per subunit in that chain and this
is telling me how much of the blue stuff
that I put in there and when there's
none it's completely empty okay it looks
just like that and if I add a lot it's
completely full every seat is taken okay
and in between we have this s shape in
that s shape without going into details
immediately lights up a little light
bulb in biochemists heads because this
is something referred to as
cooperativity what it means is that in
the beginning it's hard to put a couple
of these blue guys on but once a few of
them get on then it gets easier and
easier to get them on until the whole
seat is full can you see how that right
so I put it in nothing happens and I put
it in a little bit more than all of a
sudden
oh let's all go there that's the cool
party hey that is referred to as
positive cooperativity and so the
question is is how does this tell me
about the energy that's what we're after
and so we use a model okay I know that
an actin filament looks the way I showed
you
I know it's just double chain but I said
I'm just going to assume it looks like
this okay and it why because it's simple
and we like simple models and we use
them until they stop working but we
don't complicate things unnecessarily
until we have to and why is this model
very good it's very good because you
only exist on this chain three different
ways you can sit by yourself you can sit
like this one with a buddy on one side
or this one that's got a buddy on either
side that's it just like the people
sitting in this room somebody sitting by
themselves some people they're sitting
together and there's even a group of you
okay now if you didn't care that someone
was sitting next to you there would be
some equilibrium constant don't worry
about it what it means just know that
there's this number that tells you how
likely are you to get on there but if
you'd rather sit with the buddy you'd
rather sit next to someone which most of
us do unless we're on an airplane the
there's a little bit term that tells you
how much better does it feel how much
better or harder is it to sit next to
somebody okay
and this is wonderful because this to a
physical chemist has meaningful
information about energy which I'm going
to tell you about but what I want you to
understand is the logic and how you get
this information
okay and so what's nice about this is
that with this little model here you can
make very specific predictions about
biochemical States what do I mean by
that okay what do I mean by this
okay let's take an example let's just
say I asked all of you to leave this
room and then I said I'm gonna come back
in and let's say let's get thirty of you
to come back in and let's assume that
you are you'd rather sit next to
somebody a hundred thousand times more
than you would rather sit by yourself
okay send you out and thirty of you come
back in what are you gonna see when you
come in you're gonna see everybody
sitting together yeah fair enough
now what if I said send you out again
and next time you come in thirty people
come in and you'd rather sit by yourself
you know sitting back leaning over on
the Amtrak a hundred thousand times more
then you would rather sit next to
somebody what are you gonna see everyone
sitting apart so what you just did what
you just did was make a prediction and
you made a prediction because you had a
model and you had some information and
that's why we spend our time doing this
precisely and we can do exactly the same
thing here I just told you that when
cofilin binds it makes it easier for the
other ones to get on so that means they
like to sit next to each other in the
same way that you just told me how big
this group would be I can tell you how
big these little groups of blue are on
that filament and when I do that you can
see that this is the amount of blue
stuff that I add and this tells me how
big is that cluster how big is that
group okay when I added nothing there's
none but then I start adding it and it
goes up and it goes up and then I add
more the group gets bigger and bigger
and bigger as I start adding more people
in here the group gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and so this was great I did
this and then when I did all of my
calculations which are right there you
don't have to worry about I went back to
the library and I said when do people
actually see this blue cofilin protein
cutting the actin and there are lots of
experiments in the literature and I'll
show you one where they put a half a
micromolar if you don't know what
concentrations are doesn't matter they
put just a little pinch just a little
just enough okay and so I said hey how
big is this group at this concentration
at this amount how big is the average
size of the group and now you look on
there and it's how big is it
anybody see it's about one
so what that's telling me is either I
made a really serious mistake which I
don't think I did and we know we didn't
now but it's telling me that even though
I've been told this 20 times or more
it's telling me that this model that
this thing binds over here and causes us
to break is either incomplete or it's
wrong and that maybe even just a couple
of these little things just one or two
or a few can actually cause this thing
to break I'm going to get back to that
because this telling us that our way of
thinking may not be right even though we
were told enough times that we believed
it and so what's particularly nice which
is what I was getting at is that we can
get information about energy that's why
I started all of this ok and what do I
mean by that is I showed you those those
numbers before how likely are you to sit
down and how much do you like being next
to somebody
these have meaningful physical chemical
definitions that tell us about the
energy ok we don't have to worry about
the details but what matters is you have
to think of energy like money ok and so
money comes in two forms let's say you
can have a soccer ball that cost ten
dollars or you can have ten dollars
which one is going to let you go to the
store and buy candy ten dollars there
both have value they the energy comes in
two forms okay it comes in something
called enthalpy and entropy but in the
same way knowing how the money is stored
tells you something about how you can
use that money and similarly how the
energy that's driving this thing to
break is converted or it's revealed or
expressed itself if I can use these
terms tells us something about how this
energy is being used to break the
plastic and long story short a couple of
years later we find that entropy wins
and what we've learned is that when this
blue protein cofilin binds to the actin
it makes it wiggle it's not very
fascinating to anyone here but it's
pretty important and so the question is
what is
actually mean so we can look at these
things
this protein cofilin when it binds to
these actin filament it makes it
jiggly-wiggly and floppy and this is key
to causing it to break and so what do we
do well we actually measure what what
motions does this polymer exhibit and if
you guys want to play with some of these
you can play with these here maybe you
can give a couple of these out
especially for the little kids they're
fragile they may break but look at this
how can you move this little thing
around you can play with it sweetie yeah
there you go and uh you go a little man
and then you could pass them around what
did what is this thing gonna do okay
well these little things can jiggle
around actually do because there's
temperature but this thing can twist and
it can bend ok this rope does a much
better example of it like it can twist
it can bend okay and so the question is
is when this protein binds to it it's
causing it to bend twist or do all these
things in some way we have to understand
what that is because that's what's
causing it to break and so here's a very
simple experiment conceptually very
difficult experiment to do we colored
these actin filaments okay and we just
looked at them in the microscope and we
combined them to a little flat chamber
so they're really sort of like wiggling
on a table okay and then we just watched
them wiggle that the temperature caused
them to wiggle and in yellow I got a
straight line and then in blue I've got
a regular actin filament that's just
jiggling around a little bit and then in
red I have an actin filament with these
Co fillings all over the place now my
mother can look at this and say the red
one bends more and she'd be right and
that would be consistent with everything
that we've done but the same way that
you have a model and you have numbers
without numbers without numbers and
without a model you can't make
predictions and so we want to express
this floppiness in real numbers and how
do we do that it's actually a very
simple simple conceptually very simple
experiment see this pencil go back to
this pencil I like pencils okay so you
see that okay that pencil
I take this hat and I move this and just
like that let's say 45 degrees what
happens to the other side it goes it
moves exactly the same amount right
why because it's a pencil sir
exactly yeah you're hired man you're
hired I would have thought about it for
a little while all right but now let's
say I move this why doesn't this move
over there
because it cuz it's floppy exactly okay
so now imagine I took this pencil and I
stretched it all the way to New Jersey
and I moved it here do you think it's
gonna move in New Jersey maybe not okay
and so this thing looks straight on this
length but if it's super long well it
doesn't it doesn't really correlate
anymore
where this thing loses the correlation
on a short time scale it's obvious but
there's a number that describes that the
length at which you lose this
correlation tells us how hard it is okay
and that's exactly what we did right
there that's the action that's science
that was toys but it gives you the idea
and we end up with these numbers okay
don't worry about what they are just
know that we have these numbers and we
can do the same for twisting I can put a
piece of tape on here and if I try to
twist it it won't twist right it's
harder to twist and if it's floppy it's
easier to twist okay and if it's super
hard like I can take this and I can
rotate it and the whole thing will move
okay and those numbers although my
mother could say all right son brilliant
that's why you went to college it makes
them bend and twist more easily but
these numbers right there the ones that
we're going to use and it's bent took a
lot of time to measure these numbers and
when you use this information at the
time I admittedly didn't know what I was
going to use it for but I knew enough
that I might need it someday so I wrote
it down and I'm gonna get back to that
in a minute but let's go back and say
where and why do filaments break that's
what I said I was gonna do and I haven't
even done that yet you realize it's a
long
of following information like a like a
dog getting clues trying to figure out
how this thing's gonna break so let's
just use a little bit of logic okay we
know that the energy of binding that
causes this plastic to break does so by
making filaments more floppy okay but we
don't know where and why they break okay
now if you tell me how many chairs are
in this group and you tell me how many
how your group is I can actually tell
you a lot more than you've told me like
I can tell you how many people they're
going to be sitting on the ends so if
you tell me there's 200 seats in here
and there's a hundred people I can tell
you nobody sitting on the end you know I
mean except the wall but this
information is there and we can go back
to that simple model okay and that's
even though I said they're all bound you
can actually exist in these three
different ways you can exist like the
red one by yourself this little orange
one at the end of the seat or this green
one that's sitting in the middle now
what's really nice is that when there's
just a little bit of this cofilin they
kind of sit by themselves and when it's
full when it's full it's all green so
does it break where the green ones are
the orange ones the red ones or these
purple ones that's where this
mathematical model this conditional
probability model allows us to make some
predictions that we can then test with
the experiment okay and a long story
short we said what are the chances of
this thing breaking and I'm going to
show you a movie where we can watch it
actually break and I'm going to show you
and what we learned is that when it's
completely empty or completely full
like those two pictures I showed you in
the prone in the beginning it actually
doesn't really want to break this had
not been anticipated and in fact it
actually breaks when it's half-full and
so what's interesting is that we then
did a correlation we modeled the amount
- the density of these different species
and we've said aha maybe it's breaking
the junctions between these floppy parts
and these stiff parts and then we took a
movie here again is an actin filament in
red and then we took this protein and we
colored it and you can see it binding
and then you'll see boom it does in fact
start to break at those joints wonderful
ok cool so now we know where it breaks
but we don't know why they break
ok so we've answered one of the two
questions
it breaks at those joints those
junctions and we let's how why might
this be possible
well the green one and a red one are
different ones floppy the other ones
stiff ones got a little bit of different
twist than the other ones they're
different and you know the question is
is maybe these two phases don't like
each other thanks for this Curt just
like oil and water right they're mixed
together okay but the water rather be
with the water and the oil rather be
with the oil so they're just gonna
separate and then there's like a
boundary between those two and here you
see a wonderful example where you can
actually separate things into phases
based on their physical and chemical
properties and so the question is it's
like maybe it's that simple maybe I'm
thinking too hard about it maybe they
don't like each other that's possible
question is is there any reason to think
that this might be the case I can think
of other reasons so my student Brandon
did a great experiment he said well
let's just look at it when it breaks and
then he saw a regular actin filament and
he said hey you know sometimes I do this
and we bend them with microscopes and
things like that but here's an example
where he said when I saw it break like
it bends a certain amount and they
brought it snaps and there's some angle
all right and then he took the ones that
were all green and they break in two
places but it doesn't matter they also
break okay and they break at some angle
and then he looked at these joints and
he looked at when they break and they
break at a smaller angle in either
parent filament okay it's just an
observation
and that observation itself is it
actually I have to bend it less to break
it there so it's kind of like
a bad joint okay there's a lot more
information in there but we're already
getting the idea that maybe they're just
different from each other and they
actually don't really want to be next to
each other so they they break by
themselves they're because they're
different they're apples and oranges and
so I got together with my friend and
colleague Chuck Sindelar and we said
well what we really need to do is we
need to see what that boundary looks
like and so Chuck and his student Andrew
hilling looked in the electron
microscope and we got an atomic
resolution structure of this thing and
you can see the co filling which is now
green is sitting up there and then the
other section is right there and it's
breaking right there but we don't know
why we know that we just twisted jam it
a little bit and it wants to fall apart
but we don't really know why okay we can
talk about energy we could talk about
structure we can talk about mechanics we
could talk about a lot of things but we
don't know why it breaks because we
don't know what it looks like and so
Chuck and Andrew got a wonderful
structure and if you look here again a
different color sorry about that when
the co fill-ins there it actually puts a
little hole those actin subunits are
holding on to each other and when the co
filling binds it puts a little hole
where it's normally holding on and so in
fact it actually really is a bad joint
because instead of holding on to each
other these subunits the co filling
comes in and causes it to compromise
that contact at that Junction and that's
why it breaks more easily so this is
good because we got a good idea now of
why it's breaking and as much as I love
working with purified proteins and
controlling these experiments life
inside of the cell is quite different I
have these things sitting in a tube
flopping around just jiggling around
like because of thermal energy but
inside of a cell that's a rough
neighborhood okay they're they're
sayings being squeezed and pulled and
pushed and there are other things
specifically there are forces
acting on these cells that might affect
this and I'll give you a very simple
example from my friend Paul fortune
this is a neuronal cell from an organism
called a please yeah cease look but this
is a beautiful neuronal cell and this is
all the actin cytoskeleton that I told
you about and this is this you can see
the actin to range in these little
orthogonal matters you got these long
long fibers and bundles and when you
look in there Paul noticed he's like hey
some of these are kind of caked this is
interesting okay and then more
importantly Paul started looking at this
and he can see that they when they get
kinked boom they start breaking okay so
these cells are experiencing these
compressive forces as they're trying to
push it's pushing back and then it's
squeezing them and causing this to break
okay and there are other proteins in
there called
motor proteins that are squeezing and
helping these things move around and he
went in and he poisoned these motor
proteins you see out of a drug boom and
then ah and then it stops breaking aha
so this is telling us that this
squeezing inside of a cell is promoting
this breaking and the recycling of the
subunits and so the question I have is
this added energy promotes this work
that these cells are doing causes these
filaments to break and recycle but how
do we test this how do you measure the
effects of forces on these things in a
cell we're trying things we're doing
things with purified components but this
is where mathematics is actually really
really helpful
specifically theory so I worked with a
colleague of mine in France Jean Louie
Marcel and all on bless Ron and we
worked out this equation here which is
elasticity okay it looks like a
complicated equation but this is telling
me the elastic energy what do I mean by
that see this I twisted that right
there's energy there
this could be a little plain I could put
it on a little boat in water and that
boats gonna go right
so there's energy stored in the shape
that I can use to do work that's what
elastic energy is okay if I bend it a
twisted a little bit there's less energy
than if I twist it a lot does that make
sense that's all that is that equation
tells me the elastic energy this terms
right there don't worry about it they're
constants they never change okay and
this term right here is bending okay
that term right there was the thing I
measured 20 minutes ago actually a few
years ago okay so what does that mean
that means if I take this and I bend it
a certain amount those little k's those
kappas tell me how much I bend it let's
just say I've been to 25 degrees and
then I let this go and I try to hit you
with that what's gonna hurt more that or
this the pencil why yeah there's several
correct answers to this yes it's harder
that's what you just said is because if
it's harder this number is bigger the
pencil has a huge L and if I bend it a
certain amount there's more energy
stored there so when I hit you boom it
hurts okay
oh and this one over here is twisting
and I measured that too so I was like I
knew it was gonna be useful for
something I didn't know at the time and
then there's this last term over here
which is coupling which I spent several
years I think me four years of my life
on this so let me explain to you what it
is you see this it's that this this this
Bungie thing I take it and I twist it
and still kind of flat right kind of
straight not a whole lot of excitement
going on right take this rope do the
same exact thing I twist it what's gonna
happen to the rope
oh it bends it's fascinating isn't it
so I spent four years of my life on this
because the problem is is that coupling
between those two motions is there I
want to know the energy in this thing
that's causing it to break and I don't
know what that number is and I don't
know if it matters and I don't know if I
can ignore it like everyone else does
so we spent a few years making a
mathematical model long story short we
measured it you think we know what it is
so now I can tell you how much energy is
in there if I start to squeeze and Bend
and deform these things and so my
student Tony developed a very
sophisticated mathematical model of this
but I'm going to summarize it quite
simply he know what these subunits look
like they're held just like this thing
right here he made a computer model of
this okay we know the size of these
things and we know how they're touching
each other right those of you that could
see it they're touching each other here
laterally and they are really like
little Springs holding these things
together and so we just modeled them as
little Springs and then he did exactly
what I just didn't you just did it cept
he did it on the computer but because
they did this in the computer and we
have this good physical model we know
where the energy is all along the length
of this thing and we can see how the
energy is causing this thing to break so
he did that and here's a very long story
summarized is that when you have
something that's half hard and half soft
you get some very interesting behavior
so you see this this is fine I do that
you see that it's symmetrical right it
looks you know I cut it right down the
middle the left half is the same as the
right half I could take something that
has a different different material same
exact thing looks the same okay but when
you have something that's half hard and
half soft it's different I know this is
obvious that's why I made this but the
soft part falls apart the soft part
moves okay and so here's a mathematical
model of that here's the soft part
here's the slightly harder parts
as dramatic as this but you can see that
the soft part deforms okay and what you
can see in yellow is where the highest
energy is just like this little toy
right there
where does it hurt right at the joint
right at the joint is where it hurts and
so Tony went on and he made lots of
movies here's just an example of the
movie where you could see where it
starts to hurt where the energy
accumulates this is a regular actin
filament but you see start squeezing it
and then the doll boom and it breaks
okay and that's telling us how it works
it's showing us that that joint is
vulnerable but also because if you have
something that's half hard and half soft
you actually localized a little force
there and so why does this matter I'll
give you another example how many of you
like to cook how many of you like to eat
okay good good I see someone didn't
raise their hand how many of you like to
eat and cook asparagus ah voila okay
super okay how many of you like just
like hardwood apart on the bottom and
there's always one freak in the audience
I know it sorry that's usually me
kidding me that's okay yeah actually
kind of like it how many of you just cut
that hard part off and throw it away in
the compost yeah okay all right well
here's I would amuse you with a funny
story but I won't well let me ask you a
question how do you decide where to cut
it I know you know the answer who those
of you who cut it how do you determine
what do you just look for the white part
I mean it's actually a pretty serious
matter you know not to be just think
about it okay so if you leave too much
of the hard part in there it's a choking
hazard no one wants a guest at the
Google at the table okay I'm pretty sure
of that and if you cut into the nice
fleshy part well then you're throwing
away food and well we all know why we
shouldn't do that so how do you decide
where to cut it
and let's ah you know I'm sorry sweetie
okay oh I can't here even win some
screams at me yes exactly so do you want
to show us how you would break it how
many of you cut and how many of you Oh
turn around show them again look at that
look at that yeah this is this is your
part this is my part so show everyone
again how would you do that how does it
work who does who doesn't cut how do you
do it so it's very similar so if you
remember anything that I told you don't
waste food and and don't cut your
asparagus if you simply just take it and
boom it actually breaks pretty much
right where you want it to now this is
an oversimplification because this is in
a step there's a gradient it's it's not
that same but conceptually it's the same
you throw that part away and here's all
the good part and you don't have to
worry about anybody choking worry about
other stuff you don't have to worry
about that now what's really cool what's
really cool is that if you now take a
little segment which is what actually
happens inside of a cell oh that hurts
doesn't it that hurts a lot and my
student Tony can calculate how much it
hurts because how does this the polymer
respond to that this filament it
responds to that pain by breaking and
when he does that he calculates it from
the energy and he finds that because you
have this soft little squishy part in
there that you can break a million times
faster and what we're desperately trying
to do now is find out if any of this has
anything to do with biology because what
it's doing is it's telling us how we
should be thinking about this problem
and sometimes we're right sometimes
we're wrong but if we know how to think
we know what to do next
and this is telling us something that
the biologists have told us a long time
ago it doesn't work as good as you think
it does and by that they're saying cells
do it much better than you can do it
with your pure proteins and it might be
missing something and that's something
could be another protein that something
could be a force and this is what we're
testing with my friend pal for sure
so I'm gonna stop there I think I'm on
time which is unusual and so what we've
learned is something that I have
honestly spent ten years of my life
working on and we've learned a lot of
interesting things along the way that I
don't have time to explain to you and
we've done other things but the point
was when I got interested in this
problem ten years ago I just wanted to
know where does it break and why does it
break and sadly we all thought we knew
that already but it turns out because if
you look closely you might realize that
even if you're told something over and
over and over again it's true it may not
be and the evidence supporting it may
not be very convincing but it was all
driven by curiosity and we've learned
many other things etc but I know that
this little protein cofilin will make
this plastic like filament wiggle around
more makes it bend and twist more and
then it breaks right at those junctions
because it's floppy it changes it and so
that little segment doesn't want to be
with the other one anymore
and then if you start squeezing on it
that vulnerable joint is even more
susceptible to the squeezing forces
because it gets compressed and when it
gets compressed oh that hurts
and causes it to break a million times
faster we think potentially answering or
at least giving us reasons as to why the
physical chemistry couldn't fully
explain biology we're working on it I'm
gonna stop there
want to thank my team this is an old
photo emily has gone on to UCSF and
we've got a couple new folks in the lab
when I apologize for not having a photo
to them not to you
and I want to thank my friends up here I
want to thank all of these funding
agencies and and you as well because
these save a few of the private
foundations a lot of this is driven by
taxpayer dollars and it offers hopefully
some understanding and insight to how
our biological systems really use the
chemistry and physics to do what they do
and I'll stop there thank you
[Applause]
okay so we have time for a few questions
for professor de la Cruz we have any
questions any questions any cuz one Gaby
one just gonna be one right back here
yes sir yes well it actually doesn't
attach very well so this protein actin
because it plays such a central role
there are dozens of proteins that
interact with it to cause it to do
certain things so in that cell which I
showed you if you recall some of the
filaments were straight some of them
were arranged this way they are proteins
that move along them like your muscle
your muscle has a protein that moves
along them so there it's it's such a
central and abundant protein in your
body that it's it is used as a central
player and there are all of these other
peripheral partners that allow it to do
very specific and different things and
the cofilin it's actually kind of in the
middle of its affinity for the actin but
it is one of the small number of
proteins that can break it and if it
bound to well then maybe it would break
it and never let go
so it actually binds somewhere in the
middle which will do it and then let it
go but to answer your question it does
it because at the chemical level these
sites are complementary to each other
and it actually sits right in between
those two subunits right I can explain
it sits right in between the two
subunits it's like a nice little cozy
parking spot and it sits there and it
actually holds on to this one holds on
to that one and holds over there so it's
perfect and if it goes someplace else
where it can't hold on to those three
places
well it doesn't hold on as well so this
has a lot to do with the complementarity
in shape as well as the chemical and
physical properties of the molecules
themselves for example opposite charges
tend to try to sit next to each other
and and and and neutralize each other if
I can
simplify it that way and when all of
these things are in the right place it
just sits there it's cozy
so Enrique so so when I do a push-up
does this happening I'm sure the motor
proto proteins and I'm breaking and
making and breaking no the the co feel
it well the cofilin does play a role in
muscle cells usually during development
but these are highly motile cells these
are migrating cells that are moving that
is a type of motor when I cut myself and
I and I'm and I'm healing that's how the
cells though when you cut yourself and
those cells heal they start migrating in
and that is precisely the same material
the same components the same principles
are being used for those cells to come
in and close that wound another question
right here yes sir yes they're squeezing
they're doing all of these things they
they if they're in the bloodstream
they're actually flying around pretty
fast if they could be in little in the
lymph they could be in little
capillaries where they're not moving
around as fast as in your big blood
vessels but even there it would be I'm
trying to think of an example like even
if they're float floating around like I
could be swimming in water and I can Oh
skydiving okay
I could be skydiving right I'm funny I'm
not walking but I can still use my arms
to open my parachute and in the same way
even though they're moving in the blood
if something gets to it I can move
around it and I can still squeeze that
bacteria and eat it so the the how the
forces are balanced to give you these
different kinds of motions is very
context dependent but it isn't
necessarily the whole thing moving the
examples we talked about were cells
moving but the so can also just move
here just like you can move your arm I'm
not moving for my position at all but
this is essentially the same as this
great so wait one more one more question
yep yes um well I guess it depends on
which garlic and olive oil you put on it
yeah yeah um you know I do actually I do
and I like it slightly undercooked
yeah but but I didn't when I was your
age yeah so so it's okay don't worry you
might you might come on to it
yeah okay let's take professor de la
Cruz rear fastening seminar okay so
we're not we're not
[Music]